August was quite a packed month and
although i didn't get everything
accomplished that i wanted to which is
pretty much par for the course i did get
quite a bit done i also got some good
vacation time in with my my wife and
i'll talk about that a little bit
September is going to be very packed
very busy and I'll talk about all the
different things we've got going on in
September but first I want to really
highlight one big development that
hopefully by the end of the month should
be ready to roll and that is we've
thought for a long time about how to
organize the various videos that we have
and you know where to put new content
and we decided a while back you might
remember in one of my other videos that
the best way to do this was to actually
start creating new channels which is one
of the options youTube allows us content
creators so I decided that the first
channel that I'm going to do that with
and this is kind of an experiment is one
that will be focused on critical
thinking logic and argumentation more
broadly so not just logic or formal
logic and and critical thinking but also
some other aspects of argumentation
communication theory that sort of thing
so I haven't started yet producing
videos for that but that's going to be
happening this month and then I have to
start curating the content and
organizing it and deciding what you know
what to do next I'm open to suggestions
for that and I'll certainly take them
under advisement so in any case on back
to August what took place in august i
would say you know a lot of it was my
traveling to other places first it was
Vermont for close to a week really about
four or five days and that was to go up
for the ax player no wood block
conference and then it was a much bigger
trip from which it was just
recovering until this last weekend to
Switzerland to Sasuke and Switzerland my
wife was studying at European graduate
school which is a very short residency
but the extremely high intensity
graduate program in philosophy Media
Studies they do a number of other really
interesting things so I went for her
last roughly week and a half and I'll
talk about that in a minute first let me
come back to to wood block so a planner
was a company that I very much like and
I'm contributing to by way of creating
class content and proposing new classes
and the wood block conference was their
first conference a player down is based
in Berlin in Burlington Vermont and
they're focused on changing the nature
of online education they've got
accreditation in state of Vermont
they're working towards regional
accreditation and they've recruited
instructors like me saying create your
dream class and will will pay you well
because you get to set the what it's
going to cost for the students and as
opposed to most places where you get you
know eight percent ten percent you get
at a minimum eighty percent perhaps even
up to ninety percent of what you take in
so you know it allows you to set the
class prices low and still make a much
better living as an adjunct than you
would teaching for other places so I'm a
big booster of the plural and I went up
to the the conference Rob skiff was nice
enough to actually host me in his home
with his with his family and we got to
do a lot of one-on-one talking about you
know education as an industry where
things are going in the next 10 20 years
how to position classes for a player now
and what they were really interested in
in this conference was how to build
degree programs there were some other
things that I was particularly
interested in so I started out you know
by hosting a panel via
google+ hangout on the future of higher
education and then we had sort of an
impromptu discussion I realized that it
could be a good opportunity for Rob and
I to discuss just what sort of
capitalist models or marketplace models
a player know is is using and how that's
different from what's going on in a lot
of other higher-end so I put the links
to that below on too EGS so I you know
took me a while to get there I had to
drive down to JFK park the car get on
the plane fly to Zurich once I got to
Zurich it was morning you know I wasn't
able to sleep through the through the
plane ride but you know now it's time to
start a whole nother day and then I had
to take it the train down to this and
then take a bus all the way from this up
the sauce fee which is really in the
heart of the Alps beautiful beautiful
country high altitude which took me a
little bit of time to get used to the
you know the further you get up the
thinner the air gets the more that you
have to work so it was great to go there
EGS is a really unusual program with
respect to continental philosophy like I
said it's it's low residency but the
residency that the students do is
extremely high intensity they bring in
some of the really big names of
contemporary continental philosophy as
well as some people that are doing
interesting things inside the history of
philosophy they bring in film makers
it's really a cool program and I'm proud
of my wife or for doing it and for for
you know staying on point with it so I
went up and my intention was to you know
shoot some video and go to some of the
lectures and when I got there they
really getting a big honor that gave me
visiting scholar status for for the year
which was quite cool and I guess it's in
part because of the YouTube video work
that I do you know
like the half-hour Hagel series or the
videos on Heidegger some of the students
up there actually use them as some of
their preparatory materials so visiting
scholar status gave me the ability to
sit in well not sit in but actually
participate in a class and so I chose to
do one on Schopenhauer that was really
great I enjoyed it I learned a lot about
a guy who haven't paid as much attention
to in the past I got to go to the
nightly lectures with with my wife there
was a lot of fun i got to meet all the
you know a lot of the EGS students which
was was neat because they they're a very
disparate bunch from all over the place
they've all got projects going on a lot
of fertile conversations got to meet
some of the professors and i also got
tapped to participate in a dissertation
defense which meant that i read one of
the students dissertations through
several times actually and came up with
some fairly detailed commentary on how
it could be improved where the
weaknesses are where the strengths were
and participated in the defense so I was
really honored that they liked my work
enough I do some work in continental
philosophy but i'm more of a historian
of philosophy as you know so it was you
know it was very collegial for them to
do that um what else happened in august
i did a doctor souther philosophy for
him just this last week with a great
guest Michael Connell you can see the
link to it below I really I I always
enjoy having guests on in these these
forums but I really enjoyed this one
because I got to pick the brain of a
practitioner of an art that I'm very
interested in and I admire but i have no
facility whatsoever and that's comedy so
i got to talk with this guy who you know
really on the ball when it comes not
just a doing comedy but the thinking
about comedy so you can see the fruits
of that there i restarted some of my
blogs and that
was a big thing for me um it's kind of a
commitment to have a blog and as usual
you know when I do things do I have just
one blog no i have several blogs i have
a main blog which is rexius do you know
NTK that's Aristotle's term by the way
for desire or effectivity that's
inhabited or structured by by intellect
so think of it as smart feelings right I
restarted that and I also restarted
Sadler's existentialism updates i
thought you know it's about time that I
actually put some new material in there
I've been doing these talks on
existentialism getting the class right
in a role I should let you get that
going and then more out of out of a I'm
not so sure that I actually have a lot
of competence in this area but I
certainly have a lot of enthusiasm and
interest I started up heavy metal
philosopher again which is a blog in
which I write about you know bands that
that I find interesting and what I find
interesting about them i write about
some philosophical problems transposed
into the arena of heavy metal like you
know I've got a piece coming up soon on
when does a band actually quit being the
same band sort of like that you know
ship of theseus example if you don't
have any original members left by you
know 20 years down the line is it really
still the same band aid those sorts of
things so I started those up again and I
created another blog for the half hour
Hagel series just to curate things to
provide resources I realized that what I
need is sort of like what I did with
virtue ethics digesters sailors
existentialism updates I needed to have
a site where I could bring together the
things that I had wanted people to have
access to I did some writing but not as
much as I would have liked to have done
I did I you know I'd finished up with
the piece on lacan earlier this summer
and so that allowed me to work on my
paper on an some and mercy and justice
that's that
present at the American Catholic
philosophical association later this
fall and I've been doing some work on
the Aristotle book projects you know
writing some material here and there
some stuff on anger some stuff on
leadership some stuff on other other
topics as well I did quite a few videos
I got to do several half-hour Hagel
videos I know I'd wanted to do one each
week but you know I felt justified in
taking a break now and then I did a Q&A
10 shorts video i did some play-doh core
concept videos mostly on the Credo and
it was happiness happens month so I shot
a few videos having to do with that idea
of happiness happens month and you know
more broadly what are some philosophical
takes unhappiness and next August I'll
do some more of those what else I did
some help outs through you know the
Google helpouts thing it's sort of like
a tutoring session or you want to talk
with the philosopher about some
particular things I also helped some
some students by constructing some self
study in philosophy materials for them
which I'm still in the process of
developing more and I started doing some
of the preparatory work to start doing
philosophical counseling including
getting all my documents that i needed i
had a few inquiries i gave them the
materials and so far they haven't
actually started doing any sessions yet
but but hopefully this falling will so
that's august what do we got going on in
September so we didn't have a glimpses
of existence lecture series and video
from the existentialism talks that I've
been doing in August in part because of
Labor Day Labor Day weekend meant that
normally the day that we would be
meeting you know Saturday the thirtieth
library was closed so we're doing it
later this week so we actually have two
of those this week
september's sixth its Heidegger that I'm
talking about that should be interesting
because if you've ever read any
Heidegger you know that there's a lot of
explaining to do when you're when you're
talking with people about it and then
later on in the month September 27th
it's going to be John Paul Sartre so two
glimpses of existence ones we're doing
another dr. Sadler philosophy form with
a special guest this time it's going to
be a friend and colleague of mine
somebody I've been working with on a
very important project of his that I
think is going to do an awful lot of
good I don't want to say too much about
it yet but i'll just tell you his name
it's leandra lima and we're going to do
a session on September 13th or the 20th
depending on on scheduling I'm supposed
to be doing a current research workshop
down at felician college place that I
like to go to quite often on Plato and
the nature of the virtues you know what
what actually is a virtue according to
Plato but we don't have that scheduled
yet it's probably going to be later in
the month I'll put more information
about that or you can go to my facebook
or my google plus page once i actually
have information will be set up as an
event i'm contributing material again to
the punk rock philosophers show i think
i have a theology matters scheduled for
maybe this week or maybe later this
month on Augustin and his views on God's
existence and whether it can be proved
I'll be continuing my blogging work this
month that's something I want to keep
momentum going with and I'm going to
restart another one of the blogs that
I've laid down for about a year virtue
ethics digest I wanted that originally
to be a site where not only would i be
blogging about virtue ethics and issues
and that but also people could
says some of the videos that i have on
the material people could access other
resources about virtue ethics people
could you know go through a reading list
and and all that sort of stuff so I'm
going to be restarting that and
reworking that blog we've got some new
videos coming up I've got some half hour
Hagel i'm thinking i'll get you know
four or five of those out this month I
know I've been promising that I would
get kafka videos and I still haven't
delivered on that this will be the month
I promise not only on the metamorphosis
but also on the trial and maybe if I get
ambitious enough on the you know the
penal colony story and maybe the
judgment and maybe even the letter to
his father as well if I get super
ambitious I'll also do some Simone de
Beauvoir stuff I've got some more core
concept videos on Plato coming out this
month and I have enough questions now to
do another ten shorts in responses so
keep on asking those questions like I
said I've got the new channel that we
are getting ready to roll out it's going
to be on critical thinking logic and
argumentation I'm really looking forward
to this it's kind of a big step but I
think it's necessary to do it this time
because you know we've got over 500
videos in this main channel right now
and I'm going to keep on you know
producing more we're looking at at least
another two hundred with the half hour
Hagel series and with these core concept
videos I don't know how many of them I
could possibly shoot you know hundreds
so I think for other areas of philosophy
where I want to have materials for
people that are particularly interested
in that makes sense to have a new
channel so that'll be this this
September probably towards the end of
the month and then we'll be looking at
doing some other ones in October and
November the last stuff that I suppose I
should talk about i'm still doing the
google helpouts if you want to do a
one-on-one session with me
that's the way to do it cost a little
bit of money but you can also get the
first 15 minute one for free so you know
if it's worth it to you to do the
tutoring or you really need to talk with
somebody about Plato Aristotle you're
trying to do some self study I think
it's worth worth the cost I'm still
working on some more documents I'm going
to do a self study and I think I'm going
to be putting out something like like a
book this fall taking the core concept
videos that I've done on Plato and
putting them into an overarching
structure and you know something that
people could sort of read their way
through and come away with a great
concept of that hope to have my first
plural class finished and ready to
enroll this month the one on
existentialism I'm already proposing
some other classes to them I sent in a
proposal for medieval philosophy I'm
going to be setting in proposals later
this week for ethics Aristotle and
perhaps one on continental philosophy
and I'm not I'm not I'm not sure yet
also i'm doing the philosophical
counseling if you think that you've got
some sort of life problem that a
philosopher can actually help you with
and you'd be surprised how much
philosophers can actually help you with
you probably want to contact me at Greg
at reason I Oh calm because that's you
know that's one of my lines of work I I
got Appa certified this summer and it's
basically doing in an official capacity
stuff that I was doing in a much less
formal and official way for the last 15
years using the resources of classic and
contemporary philosophical texts to help
people make sense out of their lives
think their way through problems open up
new perspectives figure out how to to
improve
they're their own conditions or
characters they're their ways of being
in the world so long story short that's
what we got going on for September a lot
of stuff that happened in August I'm
really excited about where we're going
this fall with reason I owe doing a lot
more public speaking which I'm happy
about so I really like talking with
people doing a lot more writing
hopefully and hopefully a lot more video
production